[Music]
good evening it's me
markiplier here again joining you on
another moonlit night or maybe it's the
middle of the day but either way you're
cuddled up against your computer or in
front of your TV sipping on your
favorite foodie beverage and what's in
that drink melons
more melons and you could possibly count
more melons and you ever thought could
possibly be in the universe because you
are alone in the dark
cue the lightning my lightnings coming
later but you are in for a spook because
you may have come to your favorite
YouTube channel youtube.com slash
markiplier for a daily dose of horror
but I you probably would say that this
is just a name I'd like to see does a
title a medal given by the universe I'd
like to think yes I am the greatest
living melon devotee collection of melon
related furniture apparel paintings is
breathtaking mhm
ha ha it's time for my favorite midnight
snack a bowl of sliced melons luckily a
big ripe melon is waiting for me in the
kitchen
oh sweet big variety smelling at the
farmers market
it was a strange exchange the crazy old
coot behind the stall didn't take my
money instead he said no your fruit no
it's named for if you don't the demons
your soul will claim tie her to love
melons love me and one lucky food is
rating for me on the kitchen counter ok
I understand what you say oh oh that me
oh I get to be mr. Malone ok I don't
know what he thinks about melons loving
him but I have a funny feeling it's not
it's not reciprocated in the way that
you think it is when you're eating them
but alas I shock ok
this painting is called thankful eyes oh
yeah it's very thankful for you
devouring them oh this reminds me of my
own melon plant it doesn't grow for some
reason well maybe they don't like you
have you ever thought about that have
you ever thought of the possibility that
you aren't the melon connoisseur that
you think you is this painting seems to
know me better than any of my few
friends oh I wonder why you don't have
any friends I don't want to go out
I got a melon in the kitchen just
waiting for me why does this guy remind
me a wharfs - I drew this I'm so proud
of myself my extensive book collection
on Malone's
ah my ominously squeaking door oh there
she is
the melon I've been waiting for the
melon taunting me from the windowsill Oh
glistening moon lights I was just
waiting for me to rend it the hard shell
and get the juicy interior I didn't mean
to make these malone set you good thing
my spooky door is working in order I'm
sure this will go wonderfully ah what a
marvelous melon
what is happening
I have no idea
Oh God you know in a way this reminds me
of what is going on oh no what is going
on
oh oh okay my head hurts ah all right
then
hold space blow what the where the
my head hurts what the okay
all right I gotta kick the out of
you okay
normal oh hi everything goes black I
don't know if that's true baski you
think your best would be feel tired my
balance I'm betraying my kids
I can't believe I had to do that oh I
guess that's just I prepare homemade
snacks okay I'm sure these sentient
melon pieces will be extra delicious
than my normal variety okay Oh Walter
who are you yeah I am the supreme
watermelon oh you finally came you must
have heard of my collection oh yeah so a
listen we have to talk just so you know
I rarely come down to this planet I
basically never talk to people but yeah
you and I we need to talk
Oh okay what's it Oh what do you do are
melons
yeah we are watermelons we are no
honeydew no orange melons we are no
cantaloupe
we are watermelons oh right okay yeah so
this probably sounds like a small thing
to you but it is really important to us
you really say melons all the time have
you have you noticed okay watermelons
nice yeah thanks for being professional
no problem yes and don't get me wrong
like this setup you're having here it's
really nice got those cool paintings
wallpaper that's pretty impressive yeah
I know all right Walter I gotta go gotta
go back to watermelon planet really
exists good goodbye goodbye one good bye
supreme watermelon I'll always remember
you
yeah balance
[Laughter]
okay so we just got to enjoy Wilfred
Wharf a she was obsessed with melons
just beating the out of a sentient
melon and for some reason the supreme
watermelon is only upset that he's
calling him by the wrong name and not
that he's eating all of his family
members and all of his subjects and
people now that's past normal it was
made in two weeks for the watermelon
game just some alone in the dark and I
was like ah I gotta play that oh my
god I was amazing
uh-huh Frick dude that was amazing
I am a changed man what am I gonna do
with my life now
like Malone in the duct the best game
ever made 1992 game alone in the dark
which we played as kids oh man I've
never played that game oh it's so funny
it's so funny I don't know why is so
funny his name is Walter Walter worse -
jeez wilford's brother who's even
weirder and you know has a different
obsession god that's hilarious I don't
know if you find it as funny but I'm
just like I'm tickled to death by this
game I don't know why I love it so
either way that was Malone in the dark I
know it changed your entire existence
you're gonna have to go crawl under that
blanket you thought was comforting you
and watch every corner of the room for
the supreme watermelon who's stalking
you right now and if you just so happen
to be one of the 1% of people who are
eating a watermelon based treat while
watching this video
then I'm afraid it's too late they're
already in your house you can't eat
enough of them they'll overtake you and
then you will be consumed by the
watermelon instead of the other way
around okay all right that's as scary as
I can make that so thanks everybody so
much for watching hope you enjoy this
one I actually really did so uh let me
know what you think down in the comments
below and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]